[Music]
[Applause]
Thursday
[Music]
[Applause]
here that something that kind of song
before you masturbate at a junkyard or
at like a recycling center boy
yeah let's go yeah I want to thank
that's Jesse Lucero drop that in box to
me that and that hit and that's a
nameless hit that hit doesn't even have
a name to it that's probably a classic
hit and I appreciate it thank you guys
for being here today on Thursday and it
is November 30th it might be the last
day of November you realize that it
might be the last day of November 2017
I'm - I just don't - lazy to look the
damn calendar I think but I want you to
appreciate you guys for being here with
me on the follow-up we got the follow-up
this week I'm gonna get right into it
because I'm not playing and I'm saying
I'm not playing today I got my weekend
ahead of me I'm headed to Calgary
I'm headed to Calgary Canada tomorrow on
a flight with three other comedians
we're gonna go to Calgary we're gonna do
a show at a place called Cowboys and I
have never been to Calgary I've been to
Canada and I've had some unique
experiences up there got some severe
food poisoning up there one time and had
to lay by a fireplace for a long time
and and get well very Native American
experience up there and as sometimes I
wonder what happened with the Native
Americans that were in Canada because
you always hear about like you know how
Native Americans got treated here in the
US and not well my dad if you missed
those chapters in school but the answer
is not well there and then I start
thinking well how did they get treated
over there and in Canada you know this
kind of frost they call them frost backs
I think a lot of people up there and I
think I don't know if it's a racial term
or not I hope it's not but anyhow man
thank you guys for joining me I just got
out of some yoga so I'm feeling my
spirit I'm feeling my spirit kind of
living in the ends of my arms and legs
and look I'll tell you this about yoga
man I used to be anti yoga you know I
used to be anti yoke I'd go in there
people are sweat and you know you can
hear some ladies they got their hoo-has
dangling out
you know people some people's in the
corner just kind of you know laying on
the thing with like a little blanket
over them and you know they freaking
tugging out you know you know they
freaking petting that whistle bruh but
then you also have people that are in
there that are really getting it done
and getting their bones and joints in
better better condition and that's the
kind of people that I was dealing with
in there today man it's good to yoga I'm
starting to get into it they have that
Diamond Dallas Page yoga I've never done
it but I hear that it's pretty cavalier
so but I'm happy man I'm feeling good
I'm feeling lively you know I might have
to go hit that that gray block Pizza
over on Pico Boulevard roll up in there
you know peaceful roll up in there and
namaste let me get that hitter huh let
me get that great block pizza fill my
mouth what's inside of your mouth right
now probably err maybe gum maybe your
tongue imagine if your tongue was pizza
that's okay that's what can happen to
you if you go to great block pizza so
you check it out when you're in Los
Angeles GRE YB loc kpi's ez a.com we're
doing the follow up I want to get you
guys immediately into the call that led
to a lot of calls we had a lot of people
hit the hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three we're gonna
get into I'm gonna put that call for you
right now so you can hear what a lot of
the calls were about here we go hey
what's up Co my name is Adam and got a
little question for you maybe get your
thoughts a little my wife at about year
two informed me that watching
pornography was akin to cheating year
two first of all this dude I mean that's
a wild way to put it I guess Adam year
two but yeah so 700 days into the deal
you know after having the cake in the
big party with everyone and friends you
know and love and family and getting
those gifts and getting that money your
wife says that porn is a kick is akin to
cheating let's go and so she requested
that I stop watching that pornography
and so I did but what she did for me was
she allowed me to start filming us doing
the nasty
that nasty bye and you know what's
interesting to me Adam is that nobody
ever it's never I love how the nickname
it is the nasty you know it's not that
beautiful dance you know it's you know
it's it used to be called humping
sometime they call it humping you know
if you if just a woman is just you know
I guess kind of on her knees and you're
just back there behind her
you know that's humping you know but the
nasty and if you've ever watched two
people have sex dude it's kind of it's
pretty ridiculous
like I'm pornography you're talking to
the all-stars you know these are the
Shaquille O'Neal's of on
pornography on sexual you know these are
you know these are your your your you
know these are your your Neil
Armstrong's of sex and a you know you
know tits and butthole work and all of
that everything they're doing these are
kind of sewers you know these are this
is this is your salt bay of of sexuality
these people in pornography somebody
rolling into your bedroom or my bedroom
seeing you know are hairy you know Gary
Ayers that hairy air book seeing our
hairy derrieres or our you know our you
know maybe a five an ink stain on my leg
cuz a pen broke in my pocket at work and
it's been there for seven months you
know and I mean we're not showing off
the best case you know we're not showing
off the best you know
elements and the best limbs and you know
in everything so the wood you're gonna
be there trade-off I mean that's a
beautiful trade-off you know at least
your wife gave you an option she said
well if you can't do this I don't want
you doing this but you're allowed to
film you and me bein nasty
let's hear more so anyway the dark arts
part of this comes in with me
I don't want to try something else and
I'm not sure on how she's gonna take it
but I kind of want to film her banging
somebody else that may sound weird to
some people it may sound you know the
the jealous types you know they they
wouldn't get into something like that
but I've been thinking about it a lot
man and you know even sometimes when my
wife is doing nasty things to me I kind
of in my head start thinking like I'm
somebody else there you go
so he really in his in Adams head it
feels like he is well let's see what
some of you guys thought man because
he's let his wife is saying I don't want
you watching the pornography that's akin
to cheating but you can film us having
sex and now he wants to bring some other
people into the bedroom you know he
wants to bring I mean first of all you
know the number one draft pick is
probably gonna be a brother and if
you're gonna bring a you know somebody
gonna come in there with a big
instrument you over you know you could
you in there with your little
synthesizer and a brother shows up with
a big bass drum you know I mean maybe
that's what you want to see though you
know or if you get I mean you could get
eleven or nine Asian dudes rolling up on
your lady you know hanging off of her
like one of those bicycles in the
Guinness Book of World Records you know
you might have eleven or nine you know
eleven or nine Asian dudes you know some
vietze or some laotians you know popping
off given to that you know that um
what's a call when they prick your skin
with all those needles at one time I
don't know what it's called man needle
needle work you know if they Nitin they
doing all that knitting boy they you
know there's a little bitty you know
crazy hammers you know the specific
hammers a lot of Asians they come with
that specific hammer you know almost
like they got a like they're like us
like they're sewing you know they get
that little they got that sewing machine
wiener
but you get 11 of those boy you know you
could cause some arrhythmia or something
on your old lady but so that that was
Adams call and you guys gave me so you
guys
some great calls that came in so let's
pop in one of those right here this is
Ashley
I'm calling from Tampa hey Ashley thank
you for calling for Tampa Tampa bad
zoning down there you know a lot of I
got accosted by a gay gangbanger down
there one time do try to get me honestly
to masturbating and giving my wallet so
that's you know it is what it is but
they got some unique zoning down there
you know strip club right next to a
place where you could get a boat or you
know get a animal euthanized all all
types of stuff Spanish moss everything
let's hear more thank you for calling
Ashley I miss are you for the first time
a while back and I think that was the
first time I ever laughed cried at a
comedy show I appreciate that thank you
for the compliment one dude one night at
a show he laughed so hard he came out of
the closet you know he was just like
okay and his buddies are like what the
Jerald you know calm down bro have
another beer get it together bucko Oh
word I'm a big fan that's me calling in
response to your is is porn cheating
question and my short answer is no
however I think that it can definitely
be a huge issue in a relationship if the
person has some sort of addiction which
I think that one of my ex-boyfriends had
an addiction and yes I mean I I don't
know if one of your ex-boyfriends has
did have that but I certainly have been
there you know that is a bad habit and
it's a dark that's that's the dark
hearts and that's where a lot of the
dark hearts even started for me was
getting caught up in that you know and
just feeling around you know some of
them is I used to blindfold myself and
and pretend I didn't know where my penis
was and then find my penis and then
masturbate so you know just because you
got to spice it up even when you're just
masturbating you got to spice it up you
know but yeah for some people it's a bad
habit so you're saying no Ashley and
it's nice to hear a woman's voice on
this I'll say that there's something
immediately
you know takes it to another level when
you who got when you got a woman talking
about sexuality in that you know right
here in this conversation in this you
know in this vile little cauldron that
we've created here to discuss this dirt
topic you know homework it was to the
point where he would rather lock himself
in the bathroom and jerk off and ooh
that's a little Silence of the Lambs II
you know he's in there petting that
black sheep and you outside looking for
some wolf you know so yeah that's wild
I've never you know I mean I you know
honestly I'll tell you this I did have
times where man I would mast I would
when I was seeing a guy I would
masturbate even when she and I were not
having good sex the sex was not we were
not even having sex at a time and I
would still be pleasuring myself you
know so at that point there is something
going on because you know this was a
girl that I loved you know that I was in
love with and I don't know why wouldn't
you know exercise that sensuality with
her and instead you know you know I'm
out you know beating that thing like
it's a bad school boy you know like it
just failed the third grade you know I
you know I don't know why why why I do
that why I did that or why someone does
that you know you really got me thinking
here now actually I think some of the
reason was just I almost wonder if
someone was out of a selfishness like if
I don't like the more I connect with
this girl the more in love
maybe I'll fall more in love and maybe I
get my feelings hurt you know whereas if
I just pleasure myself then I know I'm
in control of everything I'm in control
the situation nobody can hurt me
I don't know interesting no let's hear
more thank you for calling Ashlee um so
I feel like if that's where you're at
and he's not willing to admit so there's
an issue then I think that's fair to say
that you know he's obviously stabbed but
cheating now there you go it's not
cheating she said unless it's a bad
habit but obvious in his wife must have
thought it was a bad habit if she said
that if she told him to shut it down we
got some of the great calls that came in
let's get right into it you know this is
Rico calling from that New Hampshire
Rico that HAMP that HAMP city am calling
about the porn cheating hadn't
considered it until Adam brought it up
on the call where his wife called them
out but after thinking about it I do
think porn is cheating I believe that I
have been cheating on my girlfriend
there are times where I will masturbate
before being her because I don't want to
engage in sexual activities with her Wow
I mean this is kind of part of what we
were just talking about like let's hear
more I'm interrupting you go go ahead
Adam sorry
that's cheating that that's cheatin
watch your hand
okay so you're saying that you even feel
like that that's cheating that if you're
masturbating
you know you dropping that ounce you
know what I'm saying
you know you work in that water pole and
and you're keeping that away from your
girlfriend then that is cheating I mean
that makes sense you know in a way like
yeah I'm keeping this for me this isn't
for you I mean that's the same thing
cheating is I'm taking I'm putting this
somewhere else I'm keeping this from you
I mean there's definitely saw you know
there's some synonymy there synonym
innate it's you're more like you said if
only once in a while thing but if you if
you're doing it instead of giving love
to your ladies and yeah I would consider
cheating if you're doing it instead of
giving love to your lady and yeah I mean
I wish you know in a collar hit this on
the hotline they said well why don't you
have a therapist calling sometime or
come
sometime and discuss some of these
things with you and that's something
that I hope we'll be able to get into
here in the new year a couple more
months here we're going to try to you
know maybe even get into a bigger studio
where we can have more applicable space
for a guest
those are pipe dreams but those are real
dreams and and some of that support
comes from people supporting on patreon
from our charter sponsor stuff like that
so but that would be great to have a
real therapist sitting in there and then
we can try to gun down some of these
issues you know walk through some of
them whenever we're on a day like this
where this is the kind of stuff that
we're talking about but if you're
keeping it from your lady on purpose
there's something going on there
you know because why wouldn't you engage
in that sex with somebody else you know
there's also a thing with the man like
once you get close it's like sometimes
whenever you get like a lot of my
buddies are in there in relationships
marriages but they have no sexual
attraction to their partner you know
it's real stuff out there man people are
really out in these skete streets and
dealing with this stuff next caller you
know Josh from Wisconsin oh and thank
you Rico for that call appreciate it
Josh from Wisconsin Wisconsin is where
they had the making of a murderer man
and that Brendan Dassey dude come on let
that boy out the best he gonna do is
maybe get a job break and leave
somewhere let that boy out dude
and he been through enough he had adult
acne as a child let him out homework I
love the podcast man I like everything
you're doing with the dark arts and
being that Avenue for us team well I'm
just out here in these I'm just um just
a crossing guard man I'm a crossing
guard he's jerking off on his lunch
break you know what I'm saying I'm out
here with you in these dark arts but um
we're heathens out here in response to
Adam the caller about porn
I don't think porn is cheating I think
as long as it's not something you do
like on a daily basis and that's the
only thing you lust for I don't think it
should be a problem I think you can
definitely watch too much of it to where
like you said you lose that desire for
your lady and putting up with all the
you know normal relationship stuff
doesn't seem
worth it if you're not after that life
after that night oh yeah and and he here
talking this young man time want that
nut and that's the thing because here's
the thing if you ain't doing pleasure
and you ain't you know old faithful and
you know and you ain't being a human
geyser and you just constantly treating
yourself to free orgasms you know like
you're the only person playing Monopoly
and you just going around the board as
many times as you want like a damn cheat
and dirt ball you know if you're not
doing that I mean if you are doing that
then yeah itself I mean first of all
you're doing your own thing so how does
a marriage is where you're supposed to
put it together you know you put two put
them body parts together you know you're
supposed to put the love because it's a
you supposed to see a woman in the
kitchen
and wanna you know treat her to some of
that uh that DNA glue you know what I'm
saying that that maker that baby maker
you know and I mean I and how semen is
not on the periodic table of elements I
will never understand I will never
understand salts is on there sodium
chloride dude
salt is gonna spruce up a steak maybe
and some maybe some tighten up some
broccoli but you want to start a family
you need semen dude salt ain't gonna get
you anything you throw salt in a woman's
vagina do they're gonna get pissed and
that's no children just anger and that's
the truth
but let's hear a little bit more but
yeah if you're if you're if you're if
you're if you're if you're spraying that
if you're giving that away all the time
to the to whatever to a screen on your
computer to the sink to whatever to the
shower drain then you're not saving that
for you need that attraction is not
gonna be there your Chi is gonna be
dissolved for your spouse let's hear
more so there's that interesting thought
here though do you think his lack of
watching porn now and not having that
Avenue to express his sexuality you do
you think that that led to his desire to
to share his a woman also I couldn't do
it I'm Way too jealous for that wow
that's a really interesting thought so
the fact that he couldn't watch porn
anymore
but he had been watching a lot of it now
he needs to see porn I mean his wife
said she was okay with him for him
filming them but that's like watching
the same porn over and over again now he
want to see somebody else on the screen
you know now he don't want to just be at
butter thighs calm he want to go to you
know um silver foxes and silver crotches
you know he want to go to black
superstars dotnet you know he want to be
he want to see some brothers throne that
javelin with the sneakers on a couple
brothers in New Balance going to town
you know a little red riding cot you
know he wants to see that you know he
want to see them aerialists you know
sometimes you can get on some of those
websites and have a Chinese man or a
Vietnamese fella or you know with just a
small Italian and they'll come whipping
off those uh those uh you know those
aerialists things that they have the
trapeze and land in a cross like that
and try to do no splash you know or no
you know try not to wake the lady who's
sleeping there with her legs open or
whatever the gist is of the pornography
but so this this caller saying that do
you think that by stopping one but
already being fused with it in his brain
that Adam now still wants to see porn
but the only way you can see it is by
making it on his own Wow this is almost
like a script for like a like a murder
or something it could be you know our
psyche is a bay our psyche it's like a
bay it's like a chef that don't want to
go to the grocery sometimes our psyche
will just use what's in the cupboard oh
if I got this already and I got this and
that's why sometimes you have to go to
therapy and you have to go to some of
these things if to talk to people you
have to let it out you know you have to
let these ghosts out of the out of your
soul you know out of your soul cave
because if you don't then the chef and
say your psyche will just use the same
ingredients
it'll repackage them so now in it and
look man it can make an ass to your
recipe before you're just watching other
people have sex on the screen next thing
you know you spend in two thousand
dollars on cameras and
and your wife's getting you know chirped
up by some bad birds that are flying in
you know people flying in on Southwest
to bang your wife man what is going on
you know what movie I watch the other
night it was horsemen on Netflix and
Dennis Quaid is in the movie and I like
Dennis Quaid because I interviewed him
one time on our allegedly podcast and he
brought some tequila two to myself and
my co-host and he got in a fight with a
parking attendant afterwards downstairs
and I thought that was pretty
interesting you know I didn't get the
statement from the parking attendant but
Dennis Quaid was just kind of TOD and
whatever who knows but I thought it was
pretty cool and what we were talking I
told him that my favorite Dennis Quaid
movie ever was this movie called
frequency and he told me that his
favorite movie he ever did was called
frequency so always respected that but I
watched horseman the other night on
Netflix if you haven't seen it don't
it's horrible it's a bad movie it's
about like I don't know it's posed to be
all serial killers I got four stars on
Netflix which means nothing and we have
no clue how they give him these stars or
whatever but it was absolutely bad and
the problem is with a lot of films you
go see their bad Murder on the Orient
connect or Orient Express
beautiful-looking nice train but you
know what I'm not paying 25 bucks to go
see a train you know like I'll go on an
actual train I'll get on Amtrak and see
a real murder
for probably the same price but at least
I get to travel across the country
halfway and the problem is with the film
industry these days it's that it's just
built in such a way that it stifles
creativity you know they deliver bad
content you know there's just a few
actors and a few a few people that keep
getting the same jobs over and over
again because they've monopolized the
industry you know there's only three or
four Studios that are even making
anything you have to go through Seth
Rogen you have to have the rock in any
movie you know these companies know that
if they make a movie that costs 100
million
and that the rock is in it they're gonna
make a hundred and twenty million after
so they make twenty million profit and
that's enough for them they know that
they can just use that cookie cutter
format every time but the problem is we
get bad content until now
now there's a new program it's called
live tree live tree comm you can go to
it right now and it's basically a
network that's going to allow us the
consumer to invest in projects and we
will own part of the project so we get
to kind of pick what will be created
imagine like fantasy football basically
where you get to put the players in
right you will help choose the actors
you will help fund the projects but you
will have an ownership you will have a
stake you will have a share imagine that
it's basically create your own pizza but
it's for film and television and that's
what's going on now and it's amazing
it's a way that the industry can change
go to live tree dot-com
check out how you can get involved it's
this is the time to get involved it's
like say if I told you five years ago
you can invest in Netflix now that's
what's going on live tree dot-com you
want to check that out I promise all
right let's go to our next caller here
this color is from Huntsville Alabama
where I was just a few weeks ago and I
appreciate : here we go what's up yeah
this is the telling about if pornography
and viewing is cheating or not thank you
for calling young bucko let's hear more
of your words I think you said it best
man if it's I had that that you're
setting aside time for and funda from a
regular basis VIN yeah I believe it's
cheating up doing while off for about
five years and anytime I got into the
habit of watching porn it always took
the excitement of having sex with my
wife away a hundred percent you know if
you got that gusto headed towards your
lady and you sprang in that gussto out
in the yard or pulling up there by the
winn-dixie and masturbating or whatever
then of course you're not gonna bring
that same gusto into the household you
know and I feel you man you know and
it's wild out there if you have it in
your planner first of all if you have it
in your planner you know
breakfast Jim jerk-off you know that
kind of stuff then you gotta then that's
definitely not good so I feel you there
let's hear some more thank you for
calling and I wonder if Adams fantasy of
watching his wife getting nailed by
another man actually stems from watching
porn I don't have any experience with
the whole cooking situation but out and
cooking he's talking about cooking and
that's the thing where you you know you
have a you know um it's basically tag
team where you tag in somebody else and
they come in and you know put your
wife's vagina into a figure four leglock
onward but I would think that being
married for only five years that it may
be a little too early to start making
those kind of requests in the bedroom
and this is my wife I know it would kind
of freak her out she'd feel like she
didn't know who I was what I wasn't the
man she married and that's a good point
you know if all of yeah you can't
surprise you can't be like hey you know
I got a new sex toy to your wife
and then you crack oh you know she's
like what is it and she's looking in the
drawers and then you next thing you know
you know she's looking in the bedside
table and I seen you open the closet
door and his big Ralph you know or is
thick Hank you know rocking out you know
you can't that's you know all of a
sudden you're a conductor you're not
even a participant in y'all's
relationship be more of a conductor at
that point you know you just fueling up
that you know you folk you fueling up
Ralph or Hank if you getting them
Gatorades or anything well they're doing
activity you know so you got to think
about some of that and yeah maybe you've
evolved into some other type of deal
brother you know Adam our original
caller maybe you've evolved or devolve
however you want to look at it you know
your tastes have changed but that might
not be what your wife signed up for you
know I mean these are his thoughts
brother let's hear some more another
caller here we go
all right there's Big Bob did I tell you
this man they had a guy in my town named
big Bobby
bobert Singh right Bobby Bob Orton and
this boy was big he might be deceased
now bless him beautiful guy but he was
so big
you you don't want him to fall on
anything sharp because he would just pop
you know what I'm saying you don't want
him to fall on a nail or anything he
would just explode and he was that big
just pressure you could see the his
insides were just pressed up against his
skin you know he couldn't I mean he
there was just nothing there was no room
for anything you know his eyes he looked
like he was just trapped his eyes look
like they were just two balls that were
trapped in his head but he used to he
eventually actually kidnapped somebody
and got busted for pistol whipping some
young fella but before that he was a
attendant at a gas station
24-hour gas station we could get gas and
different delectables mostly fatty
delectables like you know rotisserie
hotdogs and cheese dips and you know
chips slim jims gobstoppers isyes
freezies snack cakes different things
like that sometimes milk but the milk
would only last for a few days or maybe
24 hours you know what I'm talking about
gas station milk a gas station you know
what I'm talking about well he worked
there and he used to let he used to let
us go sit in there during high school we
put lawn chairs in there by the liquor
buy the beer cooler and just drink beers
back there and just sit in there like
have a little powwow right back in the
buy the beer coolers there in the
beautifully lit gas station I think it
was called him am/pm but anyhow big
Bobby of bobberts and but nice to hear
you Bob let's go you know I've been I've
been married for quite a while now
almost 15 years and who a big king say
more and you know I man I've been
beating my meat for again since the day
I can't remember and you know ain't no
wrong you know staying in touch with
yourself and you know just being one
with yourself and you know oh yeah G and
up sometime you got a drink a Red Bull
and just jerk off you know get out there
be an
doors Minh let's hear more you know men
have beaten off forever they're gonna
continue beating off and I don't know
about that we'll be you know 300 years
from now will men still be masturbating
who knows brother that's a big
speculation onward you know porn is just
a way to you know get that energy out
you know and I mean I feel like if you
take that away from a man then you know
who knows where the energy is gonna be
directed to you know for all I know you
take away my porn you're taking away my
biscuits and gravy my my freedom you
know he's taking away everything so now
you heard it you're taking away
everything if you take away that man's
pornography then what's next you're
gonna take away his guns you're gonna
take away his pudding pops you're gonna
take away his ability to buy gasoline
you know where does it stop so yeah I
mean you're just saying men need that
it's okay and look for most men it is
but this lady don't want this man having
it in the household you don't want it to
be a part of their relationship because
it affects it you know but for you it
doesn't some man I think it's an
unhealthy scenario and in and in his
situation right there it's not so big so
Bob right there is not affected Bob is
that's and that's what's referred to by
many Bob as being unaffected you're
unaffected by it let's hear a little bit
more here how's it going Theo its Mason
from Boston Massachusetts Boston yep and
I'm calling the regards but that fella
who was talking about a film and his
wife and another man having sex uh yeah
I got to say to him I don't I don't
think that's right at all she she says
that him watching porn is cheating but
then he wants her to another guy
and that's okay I don't know brother I
don't know about that that seems like
the dark arts you mean one may think oh
yeah well it's definitely the dark arts
that's why we're discussing it here
there's no doubt about it you know the
man you know she said no to that he's
thinking about introducing it you know I
mean he's got an infection he's got that
itch to see that visual you know he's
got that itch that's what I think but
these are you guys as thoughts and
that's why we have this follow-up
episode let's check in a little more
here we go hi feel I'm calling from
Miami Florida
um Oh mummy from Miami bbb-but I guess
this is a response to the guy that
wanted to bring another guy in to be
with his wife yes I send film it um as
if somebody who's married uh I don't
think that porn cheating even though I
did think that at first
I'm totally over that and I just I don't
find it cheating okay so you don't find
a cheating and this is from a lady who
is married here yeah she given her
thrown in her for sense let's hear more
however I would say that about the whole
bringing the guy into the bedroom
I think he should maybe reconsider that
or really analyze whether he whether he
really wants to bring another guy in or
if he's just tired of watching himself
in the videos that he's making at home
because if that's the case and maybe you
should just talk to his wife about the
whole porn situation I don't know I just
feel like yeah I look at him it's gonna
cut you off there but that's a great
point maybe maybe you're just tired of
watching yourself at him you know maybe
you need to spruce yourself up you know
instead of bringing another man in wants
you maybe do a disguise maybe paint your
legs dark you know why don't you you
know I know you know people don't want
to you know doing blackface and stuff
like that it's you know and you know
it's a you know it's people think some
people think it's ridiculous to do it if
you're especially if you're being
racially insensitive course anything is
but you know if you paint your body full
body or put some you know skin toner on
the Darkin up a little bit maybe do that
and then be in the videos then you can
be that kind of you know you can be that
urban gentleman you know or put some get
a tattoo get sore wear some wings or
something you can be that nightingale
you know or if you wear of us a Mexican
hat you know there's different stuff you
can do you know you can grow some of
your body hair out and be a Russian or
be Italian you know you can um you know
you can I do get Yiddish you know do
something get Yiddish man eat up eat
some bad food and then bang a little
something you know I mean there's
definitely different things you can do
so I think maybe that's another thing
you you know you might want to spruce up
or just hire a better editor maybe
that'll make the you know the stuff you
guys are filming more exciting but I
appreciate your call young lady that's a
good idea let's hear some more here we
go yo what up Theo
this is your boy Luke from California
did a glutton on some things that's been
going on in my life I've been the victim
of the dark arts
we all have been sir she's last couple
years I'm married to have a kid you know
and I love my wife I love my kids my kid
and I'm gonna save that call like so I'm
gonna save that call for Sunday I'm
gonna save that call for the Monday
episode Luke if you don't mind man I
think it just I'd like to get in a
little bit more and it seems like it
fits a little bit better for them so
we'll check in on that Monday but here's
let's check one more caller here that we
had come in talking about this this
pornography is it cheating is it not
cheating and what it looks like bringing
somebody else in you own homestead there
you know for sensual play and for you
know body joy from Baltimore across
punk-ass from Baltimore in Baltimore is
a place where if you do if you have some
spare dope and you don't feel like doing
it where you live you can drop to
Baltimore and do it nobody probably will
notice Baltimore good place to get crab
and murdered let's hear more phone in
about is porn cheating hell no porn is
not cheating now this fella sound like
somebody uh that you know familiar with
his own body you know what I'm talking
about
and I get the other side I've been to
church meetings and things trying to
convince me and show me the corns
cheating and I get it and I prep Oh
indeed the Lord will try to keep you off
your own meat you know he didn't build
you and make you into this special
creature for you to be you know you know
you know your own hand out there
in the yard more if you're living in a
fantasy world that can't be good for the
intimacy of a marriage but I just think
calling it cheating is just not a good
way to help it's just labeling people
something that they're not that the rest
of the world he's just try and be more
dramatic and that's a good point its
label yeah if you call it cheating and
as you know then it's this whole other
thing you know then it's yes it cheating
it's a great point is it cheating is it
urges this is how he's getting his
jollies you know you don't want to eat
sugar at the house he popping these
little jelly beans on the side you know
that's what's going on really here you
know it so let's hear that one more time
it's a really good point
marriage that's true
if you you know if ya if your
relationship is there with that screen
then how realistic is your relationship
in in physical form with your spouse but
I just think calling it cheating is just
not a good way to help it's just
labeling people something that they're
not that the rest of the world hates
just to try and be more dramatic it
really I just think there should be
another word for it like it reminds me
when I'm watching the news yeah that's
true this would be another word for it
you know you know Matt yeah what's in it
what's that another word you know if you
doing if you're being like that you know
if you pattycake --n you know but only
using one hand and your other hand is a
wiener in your own and it's your own
wiener that's a lot of questions there
but yeah by calling it cheating do we
just lay it we just label it or we make
it as scarier you know then you're in a
whole different situation instead of
just being you know hey my husband is
behaving like this he's doing this he's
doing these activities he's doing that
one-handed pattycake other hand wayna so
let's hear let's hear the rest of this
and there's a fire in the background I
started that fire like a safe room like
a safe fire for a joy reminds me when
I'm watching the news when I'm watching
the news and there's a story about a
little girl who's been kidnapped and
then you sit down and watch for 10
minutes and the kidnapper is her father
and we're not
sheriff he's dangerous it just seems
like just a way to get attention to
something you don't like by trying to
make a big deal about it and I know the
kidnapping thing is a much more serious
but I I've always thought that there
should be another word for that ya know
when I get your point
a lot of times yeah you get all these
Amber Alerts six seven times a night and
it's just some child's real fathers
trying to spend some time with them you
know because there's some going
on with the court so it's a real mother
just trying to you know finally get
their kid back from an evil grandparent
I agree it's a lot of clickbait out
there and so it makes me wonder too
maybe even with Adams call was he was he
framing it up is he just trying to you
know you know how realistic is he being
with us you know is he just taking us on
a wild goose chase making him think that
he's caught up in this wild universe you
know what these you know this is his
wife really think it's cheating but then
he's bringing this and it sound like he
not I think you know if we had to come
with some overall conclusion it sound
like Adams it's not making some good
choices
you know he's choosing this and he's
gonna get caught up and what happens
after that you know where does that end
I mean that's you know that's one of my
biggest things really is uh is where
does that end you know alright let's get
to one more here hey Theo
my name is Gina and I'm a first-time
caller
thanks for calling Gina that's my
mother's name you know and that's a
beautiful name I don't know we'll look
up right now what it means I feel kind
of sad that I don't even know what Gina
means meaning of Gina it's an English
it's an English name a baby name you
Regina Regina Gina Gina Lollobrigida
that was a famous Italian I guess
Gina's make great actors or singers my
mother could not do either of those and
some of them just can be good writers it
says it's an English baby name that's
all it says so anyhow we learned that
that your name doesn't really mean much
but that doesn't mean that it doesn't
mean that you don't mean something to us
let's hear a little bit more from you
Gina thanks for calling I want to
comment on
Adams holding issue will be like
that boo-boo and get that comment out
Adam you're cuckolding situation man I'm
nervous for that conversation I just
don't see it going well I don't I don't
see your wife being open to that I can't
imagine it but I do wish you luck with
that and Co I do want to say how much we
appreciate you man
I do love listening to you make me laugh
so hard and when you say at the end of
most of your episodes to be good to
yourself because we probably deserve it
man that's some of the nicest
anybody says to me all week and and and
I hope you're good to yourself too
because I know you deserve it because we
appreciate getting to laugh that's nice
you to say Gina I appreciate that man
that really resonates with me more than
here mome my own mother talked to me
some you know I don't know why it's
crazy sometimes how we can hear a
stranger's voice better than we can hear
some of the voices that are closest to
us I don't know what that is I don't
know what that is but thanks Gina yeah
you know what's he getting into how deep
sit gonna go you know Adam these women
are worried for you sound like
everybody's a little bit worried for you
you know how does this in are you
getting caught up in these dark arts how
deep you're gonna go cat daddy all right
let's take one more call here and see
what we can get caller it's Becca from
Southern California Becca thank you for
calling I'm calling as a divorced woman
of 8 years in response to Adams call
dude I had to pause your your little
video because that comment that call was
so creepy that I just I had to like take
a breath and find my cell phone and be
like dude I got a call that holler
I don't I don't make these calls but you
got to hit that hotline when things get
squirrely you know when suddenly you
feel like an oak tree because you got
squirrels we're gonna do your body
that's what you need to hit the hot
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three give them gimme gimme more
Becca let me get that hitter anyway so
Adam you are embarking on a very
dangerous path and you'll probably like
in six months be dead because like this
is the beginning of like how
murder-mystery start bro like it's all
started when Adam said hey I want you
you know have sex with my friend like
Steve it's always Steve isn't it it's
all even in hypothetical scenario Steve
being nasty yes more then Stephen Adams
wife had a thing on the side where she
was like oh no I don't like Steve but
she did like Stephen and like Oh Adams
got like life insurance and now bro you
just cut yourself out of the equation
yep right there you hear you're on you
and we might be on your way to a
Dateline episode ad AM de ad Adam Hardy
has two of the same letters as dead two
of the same letters so you're close
let's hear more oh I don't know what is
wrong with you maybe you should just be
happy with it you're doing late and
there you go that that might be the
general consensus right there
that might be the general consensus from
all of us all right I want to thank you
guys for calling in I'm tired it's late
I'm gonna get out of here but I will
I'll be back on Monday and we already
had some really good callers with some
really good stuff to go over for all two
on Monday I'll update you guys I'm
headed to Calgary Canada tomorrow some
I'm keyed up you know get up there to
visit them Canadians and look him in the
eye and just let them know that we're
doing okay down here that we're down
here battling these dark arts thank you
to our lovely female listeners that
called in and I'll see you guys next
time
be good to yourselves because you know
why he
we deserve it
[Music]